what is
up marvel lights
i'm your host josh delay and we're gonna
get to marvel's avengers
it is here the day has come ah freaking
out i hope you're freaking out
whoo wow what what a month
the game comes out september 4th i it's
less than a month away
but this month is filled with betas
which i can't wait the xbox one and pc
pre-order beta is live right now until
sunday the 16th
and the ps4 open beta is live right now
till sunday the 16th
i'm freaking out let's get into this
game let's start it up
as you see kamal and hulk are just right
there staring us down
oh oh man i can't wait i played this
game last weekend
and i i leveled everybody up to 15 and i
just
loved it i did all these things and
can't wait to showcase to you
this game and what it means to me and
yeah i just
a lot of enthusiasm as you can see
oh man i love it
be sure to ask your questions in chat we
will answer them as well as quick as we
can as fast as we can
uh we're going to answer them throughout
the show let us know how hyped you are
which is your favorite avenger to play
as if you've played this game
and so just a quick recap i'll let
jarvis speak irregular
is this safe zero zero zero one percent
chance of injury
uh okay
i trust you i guess proceed through the
crew quarters
the harm room is on the lower floor of
the hangar bay thanks jarvis
bruce banner just chilling oh let's talk
to bruce banner
something wrong i'm just a bit uneasy
if he really is there then i'm the last
person he wants to see
it's going to be okay we can go when
you're ready
repping the the black widow shirt as i
am too hey
[Music]
uh so right now just a quick recap of
what we just did the beginning of the
beta starts with a day
the biggest iconic mission you get to
play as captain america
black widow hulk iron man and thor
and then from there you do solo missions
with hulk and then kamala you look for
jarvis because you're looking for iron
man
and then you find a shield hideout and
you get introduced by nick fury for the
first time
so we just ended there so right now
we're going to the home rooms
oh phil sheldon what you just witnessed
was blurry footage from an older phone
but there's no mistaking what it shows
the incredible
now we're going to our first harm room
which is going to be a tutorial
essentially
uh teaching us um great ways to play
better
it's still hard to believe all this is
real i mean
i just flew on a quick and the xbox
premiere beta is not live just yet
sonic fury and now i'm talking to jarvis
and not keeping my cool at all
sorry no need to apologize miss khan
oh this is so cool
hormone time
[Music]
ready powering up
wow welcome to the horror holographic
augmented reality or our machine or
harmony
combat training simulation
i yes you don't mind are you kidding
yeah
i am iron man this is cool do your worst
virtual bad guys
cool so now they're gonna the game's
gonna teach me
counters parries
that was great way to get to know the
game
accidentally done
oh yeah random yep i gotta keep my eyes
on that meter
also let us know your chat who you main
as
the beta lets you play as hulk black
widow iron man or kamala
who's your favorite
i switch between kamala and black widow
i should do vaults like i'm like all
right let's do combat but
all right tutorial
so vaulting over enemies if they have
shields is very very important because
it basically puts their shield down and
opens them up for an attack
let's get to some flight
oh this controls just so smooth
oh nope that was a massive fail
i'm block i'm blocking the cannons i
can't even see them okay here we go
here we go
see i need i need the tutorial i need
the drawer here we go
there we go
ah
all right four waves we can do this
for iron man you want to balance melees
with the repulsors
because that meter on the top your
repulsors will go fast
your weapons will go quickly
i'm not an iron man man as much as you
could probably tell
but i will get better
when he gets hit and comes back like
that on this one knee
i should be countering way more dodging
i can do countering them still
there we go i'm still wondering better
that
all right it's over
[Music]
unity
cool so now we just uh unlock the war
table
and we unlocked black widow
and iron man this is a war table it's on
the uh
it's on the ship that you're on as well
chimera
and then here we go so let's go and head
and do our first mission let's go into
utah badlands
all right here we go
let's stick with iron man because i want
to i want to keep getting better with
iron man so we're going to change
change to some you know some red
atmosphere
so going uh you're going to utah
badlands communication nexus
sabotage which is a drop zone now for
those of you who are like well what's a
drop zone drop zone missions are
you know shorter missions you can play
the multiplayer as well they're more
close
quarters let's get iron man up in here
yeah we got some gear too
my companions are with me there ai uh
agents in the field have identified the
location
so i have my entire avengers squad with
me and as i level up my ai
they will level up as well it needs to
be so we just constantly get better and
better and better get in there
take out the server volts and get out
before aim reinforces the facility
oh man i better do good as iron man i
know some friends are watching and
they're like you know what hey
don't make us make iron man look good
oh that that entrance that they all come
in oh man chills
has a set of turbines powering one of
their emergency generators
disable them
this so the great way to play iron man
what i think that could be totally wrong
as well
you want to get the the enemies that are
up in the air first
because that's that's your go-to you
know iron man can fly
and you want to protect your avengers
squad below you
so you want to get everybody above
oh these peacekeepers they have these
gnarly shots
that do a lot of damage yeah just like
they're just like your avengers squad is
just fighting alongside you
look at that i can just i can just watch
them which they'd be like
you're the worst teammate because i
would just watch the entire time oh we
got some gear so we should
we should definitely add some gear
so right here in the menu you have all
these gears you can tell you so what i
love about this is gears right on the
top
up here is you have okay it wants me to
let okay cool you have melee rating
range rating defense rating or heroic
rating
each character my iron man's gonna be
different than your iron man because i
might want to go more ranged than more
or more melee you know for example i
know someone was talking about how
they want their hulk to be arranged hulk
which is just wild because hulk can
throw
like bricks and rocks and stuff like
that okay i don't have any gear
uh that i can upgrade so when i get gear
i'll show you
how each one can affect
ranged or melee now as iron man for me
my personal iron man i'd want to
probably do more ranged because of his
repulsors his lasers rockets
that's probably what i want to do so the
goal of this mission is to destroy the
turbines i believe there's
four of them maybe five of them and we
want to just go around this room
destroying the
turbines
oh that uppercut i didn't even get into
the air right with them
let's go
and before i destroy these turbines i'm
gonna
show you his abilities as well on the
bottom right you see abilities so the r1
l1
on my screen and the hulkbuster which we
have yet to
open up each time i get hit i lose
ability which i just got hit but each
time i
i give a hit
my abilities go up so i can i can uh
unlock them quicker
see i'm doing the complete opposite of
what i said you should use iron man i'm
fighting on the ground
so as you level up iron man you start
leveling up lasers and rockets
and you can change the mid combo which
is just
oh my goodness we each have their
benefits
lasers are more for like i would say
you're trying to get people around you
okay all right let's charge this
right there just one of my bills to
overcharge right now i'm doing a
finisher yes
those red attacks uh you can only dodge
you can't counter
all right they're dodging all my moves
and on the right is the unibeam so let's
see don't destroy this one
yes i didn't destroy this one over here
two two left i don't know how people get
hulkbuster in this one
but what's also crazy and i learned this
last week iron man could put other
avengers
into his hulkbuster suit
like it's insane okay i'm gonna try and
get hulkbuster for us
because like we gotta see
just don't get hit right just don't get
hit
oh man
okay i almost got it i almost got it
oh there's one up there okay sorry thank
you kamal for getting that i didn't do
my job i didn't do my job as iron man
anymore
okay i don't know if they'll give me
enough enemies to defeat
oh here we go here we go here we go oh
so black widow just did one of her
abilities to make us invisible
just save this unity for this one enemy
oh we're so close to this whole question
we can do it we can do it we can do it
hulkbuster hulkbuster in chat y'all
let's go
oh we're so close
anymore come on drones
uh all right we're close we were so
close 7 meters
oh oh oh oh one one more hit's gonna
probably destroy this turbine oh
any more people i just need one i just
need one
it's like oh i got it yeah
[Music]
oh nick of time oh
yes okay before i go to this turbine let
me show you some of these moves
hold holding does the
does the punch
oh running does oh man
and then you could shoot the i can shoot
my uh there we go
yep shoot the gauntlet out
okay let's destroy this turbine well you
got to see you got to see the hulkbuster
one more hit of a turbine needs a
hulkbuster suit
mission complete we said our first
mission
now my favorite way to play this is
obviously multiplayer with with friends
because you just you feel like you're
you feel like the avengers you're
communicating you're like all right iron
man you got up top
black widow all right you need to get in
get out kamala i need you to do this
oh it's just it's great some impressive
havoc and now aim is scrambling to
recover their lost research so let's
check our character menu out
see what gear we got
so right there that gear gives me one
percent on the heroic rating so i wanna
i wanna put that in and i got an iso
eight cool
so every every mission i recommend at
the end of a mission to check your gear
even in the middle of a mission
uh because you want to be as powerful as
you can be once you upgrade once you get
certain gears you can also upgrade them
uh i can't eat on these because they're
common but once they get into rare and
uncommon stuff like that you
should start be able to like for example
this iso eight it's rare
i can boost it uh it takes um two i
think it's uru
two uh two uru i have eight uru right
there let's boost it once
it's gonna go to power nine as my power
increases based on my gear
my power on the top is gonna increase
right here so right now in power six
the beta capture level at fifteen and
your power at forty
so keep that in mind as well and then
here's my skills i have yet to
level up my ironman to level two very
very close
this white bar right on the bottom right
here
tells me my my level percentage i think
i have probably five percent left and
then you have all these skills so you
have
here you have lasers i could talk about
this for hours here you have lasers you
have rockets
and then the different types of what
your lasers and rockets can do
you have different like uh jump up hold
hold a button to to slam
down skills that you can unlock
it's just the sky's the limit it's like
a true rpg and i'm freaking out um
i have i have i should have i should
have equipped this um
different iron man uh outfits that i
unlocked
from my challenge card that i did when i
played this last weekend which
apparently it keeps which i didn't even
know which is really cool
uh so i'm on level 11 for that
so there's tons of stuff uh when you get
into the beta you know
obviously check it out yourself play
with everything push every single button
fully customize your avenger team to
what you like
i'm gonna for sure give this a five out
of five like are you kidding me
uh so let's go ahead and select a new
hero
because we want to show people as many
heroes as we can
so let's get into black widow
so i love black widow absolutely love
black widow
quick combat in and out she does a lot
of stun damage and shock damage
so it opens people up for finishers
which is really cool so just to give you
a quick recap of what we just did as
we're getting into another
mission we did the harmon mission where
kamala got to
play as iron man and you learned about
countering
and flight and all the uh necessary
moves to perfect iron man
we just finished one of two utah
badlands missions we finished the
communications nexus which is a drop
zone again drop zones
are quick get in get out get some gear
guaranteed reward right there is a rare
artifact which we got which was an iso 8
for us
now we're going to go ahead and do this
drop zone the quantum research
bunker you can change the difficulty i'm
not going to change my difficulty
because i'm you know that shows you if
you change it negative five power we're
definitely not ready for that
uh we're going to keep it on challenge
two but there's four different four
different challenge modes you can do
so as you level up if you want to
increase that that uh difficulty for you
you don't really can
and yeah we upgraded gears and skills
now we're gonna get to black widow we're
gonna show you some
some black widow um i'm repping i'm
wrapping black widow with my shirt
i gotta get some kamala khan gear that's
what i gotta do because kamala khan is
my also next favorite
we've discovered because her area of
effect is amazing
if you gain control of the login
solutions
and then jarvis catches you up as you're
on your way to the mission
and then you'll see now this is black
widow's like entrance everyone has an
entrance do i have i think i have an
emote let's see if it's saved
let's see if i can on the black widow no
i don't got it
so black widow oh my goodness okay so
where do i start
so she gets up close and personal as you
can see she has a grapple
which is um her ability meter on the top
right there
you'll see it as i do it
let's go over here she has ranged
attacks as well
so you can play her range you can play
her up close
she can turn her entire team invisible
as you saw in the last one
aims network is equipped with a
multi-point authentication system
i need access to multiple terminals so
this one we have to
give the jarvis access
aim will attempt to initiate a shutdown
protocol so she's also good
for grabbing these characters up here
these enemy types up here
there we go and she does this backflip
oh man
she can grab onto these there we go onto
the ledges with their grappling hooks
initiated their shutdown protocol
is trying to remove me from this all
right reach the server room capture
these servers
we gotta hold them as you see the aim
percentages on the bottom left that's
going up
see i wanna i wanna show you the combat
of black widow but i gotta capture these
servers
all right we got b all right we gotta
get out of here and so
here's some ranged attacks the ammo is
on the top
don't forget to reload that is important
i always forget to reload
infiltration
come on oh man they're going so quick
come on team where you at
where's my squad at what's happening
making black widow do all the work here
i'm inside aim security system
there's one important skill for black
water which i love is after you grapple
off a ledge you can
swing further which would be very
helpful if i had that unlocked come on
hulk
help me out dude thank you
okay there 46 that's way too high okay
here we go
there we go there we go i got you jarvis
i got you
okay
so those uh those white diamonds up top
those are the hackers that are trying to
stop me from
oh no get them
i'm inside aim security
thank you
oh okay we're catching up we're catching
up we're doing good
let's see if i can do it there we go yes
okay see c's being taken over now
protocol is progressing
aim is trying to remove me oh man they
got them all what is this okay i got
distracted i was trying to
shut up oh i got to change yeah
you're lighting up in here because we're
playing his black widow now
i retrofitted the lighting for you guys
that's how much i care
thank you jarvis is so not pleased that
helps thank you
let's go invisible just to show some
abilities
oh man there's so many people
now if i was with my avengers squad and
i did that ability everybody would turn
invisible
so if you're playing with other people
make sure to communicate
let's let's do her baroque
[Music]
that was uh that was hard on my own i'm
not gonna lie
awesome so we got a question rogue angel
x30 how do challenge cards work yeah
great question i'm gonna i'm gonna pull
it up
so we just finished the mission so i
want to get into my gears and skills of
course
but let's get into challenge cards first
it will take me some time to analyze but
it should prove a boon for the
resistance
cool so there's up to
i think 40 levels that we have in this
beta uh and each
level unlocks something new to unlock
each level on the bottom you have daily
challenges and weekly challenges the
dailies obviously refresh every day the
weeklies refresh once a week and they
have the refresh
times on the bottom a challenge for
example that we have right now is defeat
enemies
while veil of shadows is active veil of
shadows is the invisibility ability
the invisibility ability that's tongue
twister right there
uh and so i defeated four while i was
invisible so i'm 40
of the way once i defeat 10 i get three
challenge points
each daily gives you three challenge
points each weekly gives you 11
challenge points
from there the points go into these uh
challenge
uh cards and you unlock them so i'm
up to level
[Music]
15. you can also use um credits
to unlock more if you want and as you
unlock more you gain more credit so if
we got to level 21 we would gain 200
credits
to do that so yeah you get you get name
plates you get resource bundles you get
emotes
just to show you how you can even get
find comics in the game and comics are
buffs that help you and bonuses
which is really cool so we have all
these uh
different uh different outfits that have
locked the challenge card
and i have an emote that i forgot to put
in before we
got into this equip it there we go and
you can preview it
circle uh but yeah so you know you can
check out these different outfits
uh for cosmetics and then there's name
plates
so we have we have tons of different
name plates you get
uh that you can unlock the challenge
card as well
and then back to the gear i think we got
do we
think we got some gear right here but
let's see that doesn't help me that's
negative 10 percent in heroic rating so
i'm gonna
dismantle that and so i get resources
for that but we got a purple iso eight
uh fifty percent reduction in heroic
energy drained by spin attacks and 25
percent less damage so again we can
boost that if we want that will go to
nine
uh and our skill tree for black widow
looks like this
you can upgrade her pistols you can get
her a high caliber shot
you can get her a full auto shot
as well and you can switch off between
that in in a mission
it's just so much you can increase her
grapple which you talk about if you hold
x while you launch off it'll actually
propel you more forward
i my jaw is is is still on the floor if
you couldn't tell
uh so let's get into
uh so yeah so just a quick recap as well
we just did we played uh as
uh iron man in our first war uh drop
zone
we then we played his black widow in our
first drop zone as black widow
and let's go ahead and showcase
kamala khan who
arguably one of my favorite characters
in this game uh
let i also okay i'm gonna not forget
this time
i believe i have some emotes and some uh
let's see let's let's go with this going
let's go with the iconic
yeah and then let's get this emote in
we'll equip it
[Music]
and then let's put a nameplate in why
not cool uh
sweet so we're gonna go and select a
mission
we're gonna get into some war zones now
now war zones are longer they're not
gonna be those quick
drop zones get in get out type of things
these are going to be like an open area
that you can
traverse around find a lot of strong
boxes
uh maybe some shield height excuse me
some shield hideouts so we're gonna go
to the pacific northwest
let's see we're gonna go to stark
realities which one is that
stark realities yes here we are cool
first war zone y'all that's kamala
now war zones are are so
like amazing because you have this
entire area you can traverse around
and if you're and if your character is
like an iron man you can be flying above
your team
while hulk is just like launching
himself up and while kamala khan is
stretching herself out and black widow
is grappling across and all this is
happening at the same exact time
it's crazy it's crazy i was playing with
friends last weekend
and we took like 30 minutes just like oh
what can your character do
what can your character do how does your
character jump locked on and ready
commander hill
good luck out there cool so we're
working with maria hill
here's our quinjet landing
so they found the location of another
aim
enlarged arc reactor and we need to
destroy it an elite aim team is close by
and on alert
updating your heart look at that
so kamala's uh ability her her ability
she can polymorph up
and get bigger so for example black
widows
was um her passive was she can grapple
and iron man's
repulsors and a shield hers
is uh polymorphing so we need to go to
so
if i if you can see jarvis if i uh if i
uh let him
know if i need some help i can i can
equip jarvis up onto my hud
and there's a bunch of uh question marks
around but for this for the sake of this
i say hey if you're playing the beta
right now explore everything look for
all the strong boxes you can get all the
gear you can
but we're gonna go here
punch these lasers out
oh man this thing's huge okay so
kamala is a big support character uh her
one of her abilities is she's
able to heal her team make sure you're
in the same area
you know what let's just dig in right
now because this this enemy is big
and i don't want to show his boss
yes going down
elevation just punt kicks people
oh he just went down
where y'all going where are you going
so as you see kamalas are all about area
of effect oh you know we got to get some
some colors over here just leveled up so
you know what let's actually because we
leveled up
let's go into our skills and see what we
want to level up so we can level up our
light attacks our heavy attacks are
arranged
there's one ability in intrinsic ability
that's one of my favorites
and it's let's see which one it is
is it sh is it
which one is it trying to figure out
what it is
it's where she spins around super quick
i'll have to find it later uh but she
spins around with her fist out
which is my favorite ability to unlock i
thought it was on the right here
whirlwind attack is it yes whirlwind
attack there it is
so i have to get level 10 in order to
unlock it but that's my
favorite favorite kamal kamalakana uh
skill
because all these enemies swarm you
and you can just area of effect out
and just keep going keep going so i just
got the spinning heel strike which is
going to help my combos
get me to the location on your heart
cool i know there's a strong box here so
this is a strong box
they're scattered around the map so
we're gonna open one
got some units and got some fragments
so there's a question mark over here
our mission's asking us to go that way
so let's let's head to the mission but i
believe on the way to the mission there
might be something we can
we can check out
bypassing their security will take
something oh she can just stretch out
keep the area clear but stay in range of
the control point
so over here there's going to be a big
baddie like a mini box you may drop
something useful if defeated
there we go there you are
eat my palm
i just oh man the way she stretches out
is so good
i'm all about area of effects
and oh man because i love that because i
like to get straight into the action
and just hit as many enemies as i can oh
yes
finisher yes stop
elbow drop
so if you're playing as kamala a good
trick to know or tip to know
keep your eye on your team's health bar
because you you you should help uh you
know heal your team if they need
that's right they were just one of the
one of the question marks
and there's there's health scattered
across so you just
punch them and you get the health right
there
so in this one we want to stay in this
this circle because we need to keep the
area secure
there's going to be tons of people i
think there's going to be a yep
now see if i had a teammate and they
were iron man these lasers on top
are brutal there's there's so many like
five of them i'd be like yo
iron man go get these but because iron
man
doesn't want to listen to me right now i
gotta do it myself thanks a lot dude
uh so let's go ahead and get these guys
out
because i'm not gonna be able to secure
the area with these
lasers attacking me and i know the aim
and i would say even if someone's
playing as hulk hulk is the perfect
person to secure that area
because he can he's basically
so powerful that he can just hold his
own
but same with kamala too because of her
area of effect
yes
i'm gonna heal so i just did my
healability
and this is one of my favorite things
let's see if i can do it let's see if i
can do it
there you are see you later dude
you just smack him across the map
so these so these i think they're
peacekeepers up here
these guys they they're lasers yeah
peacekeepers their lasers are so
brutal and that's where i'd be like yo
iron man go get him
or even black widow because she can
grapple up
because they're they're gnarly they they
do a lot of damage
as you saw my health meter like went
down almost like halfway
oh this is why we saved the amiga for
now y'all
let's get it come on dead bot okay wait
but like don't take me away from the
circle i know you're trying to do that
but
there's two dead bots so kamala and hulk
teaming up together side by side because
they're just massive and they do so much
damage
is awesome like look hulk's right there
hulk knows what's up
hulk's doing a great job iron man take
notes
oh let's get this finisher up yes yeah
oh there's so much stuff happening right
now there's so many enemies
those grenades are good are those bombs
that they keep you in a certain spot
because you can't you can't get out
oh nice black just turn that invisible
yeah turn us invisible
veil of shadows
oh hulkbuster you turn to the hulkbuster
didn't even tell me
that's cool that's so cool
there's so much stuff there's so much
happening around you
cool so we secure this area let's go
ahead and like let's do like another uh
question mark just to show you
how big this war zone is
you know if you look at every nook and
cranny which i recommend that's how the
type of player i am i look for every
single strong box i want to get all the
gear i possibly can because i want to
level up these
characters oh i think let's see if we
got some gear
oh we did we did oh here we go okay so
that lowers my melee by 13. i don't
think that's worth it
that lowers everything so we're gonna
i'm gonna go ahead and
dismantle these i'm gonna boost this
because this seems to be a really good
gear choice right here
i've been finding that i've been getting
a lot of resources so boosting
is is has been has been great i
recommend boosting if you have
the resources enough for it um oh a
challenge card a challenge card looks
like maybe we
let's see do we do it let's see what our
dailies are too
oh cool we finished a weekly that's why
we got 11 points defeat uh
protosynthoids synthoids and drones
defeat enemies while i'm digging okay so
that's going to be important every time
i get them big and i should use that as
much as possible
defeat riot bots and recover willpower
using healing spirit okay cool which is
her ability healing spirit so i'm going
to try and not
hit the health canister
what's up
see i don't want to go into that area
because i know that laser is going to
hit me
oh no i went right into that oh that's
good move oh level four
heck yeah okay let's go on this side and
get these lasers out
okay so okay there's puzzles oh i love
the puzzles in this game really cool
okay what are you doing over here get
out of here
so there's a puzzle here where i gotta
look for these
types of things
and hit him so i know there's another
one up there but the puzzle could change
one time i did this mission
and the puzzle were uh platforms on the
ground that i had to go on
so it keeps you on your toes which i
think is really cool
oh there's someone we have to rescue too
okay i got that one
let's see
okay there we go jarvis also helps you
too if you're like hey you know
i don't know where these things are let
me get drivers to help me jarvis does
help you as you can see
there's three of them or four of them
right here that jar has highlighted for
me
they give you a time limit so you want
to hit these fairly quickly
i think i have to go up there in order
to really hit that top
[Music]
let's
one
there we go oh what
what are you doing here
oh don't reset don't reset no reset we
got this we got this
yeah okay so when it makes that sound
you know you got it
so we're gonna go down here
so that door is now open and here is a
civilian that we can rescue
and this is really cool
theo comes in you're safe now teleports
in teleports them both out
there's also one up here gives me some
resources and i believe there is a
strong box
no all right let's go back to that main
mission now so yeah so so
this being a war zone you can go across
this entire map looking for
you know rescuing civilians looking for
strong boxes looking for mini bosses
let's see if we got a bunch of gear in
that
we got a skill okay so we can upgrade
okay cool or we can upgrade our
character
uh so okay holding square while in
midair breaks through the enemy's guard
which is important so you want to break
shields
while sprinting you can do that attack
coming forward
gets you straight into the action super
fast
oh battering ram oh those are good
you know what i'm gonna do
the harpoon where you can hold someone
and
throw them around like a ragdoll
i'm gonna do the breaking of the shields
because i think that's really important
we want to get we want to get shields
out
and if we lose track we can get jarvis
to help us let us know where we are
my avengers squad
which skill do you want us to unlock
next uh let us know in chat also i
should yeah
you should let me know do you want to
see
a more heavy attack light attack do you
want to see the harpoon
you know let me let me know and so
because i
equipped iron man's armor when i played
him last time
now he being my ai is now using it
so yeah
and same same with black widow so let me
know in chat what uh
what skill you want me to upgrade and
unlock i can infiltrate their security
system
head for the terminal so i can get you
inside the lab
i think over here but there's a yeah
there's a strong box here
so let's uh let's look at that thing i
just unlocked boom
a double kick down yeah sweetheart
oh what a combo i love it
that's just one level i'm just i'm just
holding square man
and she just goes i love it
ah puts him down and she brings him back
up
it's crazy how one skill can completely
alter the combos that you can do you can
get so creative with this
oh man i can't wait to level these up i
cannot wait to level them up
all right open the strongbox got some
units and fragments we're gonna go ahead
and try and hack this server that's the
next destination
we got to capture and hold these servers
we know how good my team was last time
doing this so hopefully hopefully
they've learned their lesson network is
equipped with a multi-point
authentication system
i need access to multiple terminals the
more the better
so this one gets gnarly because there's
so many enemies and then you get dead
bots as well
attempt to initiate a shutdown protocol
if they gain access to the terminal
all right let's get b and then we'll go
over to c
has initiated their shutdown protocol
the shutdown protocol is progressed
hello oh nice black widow way to go
beginning in filtration
okay here they all come
oh yes excuse me
okay so black widow's losing some losing
a bit of health there let me see if i
can find her
here she is i'm a healer boom just got
healed
and that helps my challenge card because
i need to heal i think i need to kill
anybody maybe it's just me
i have to remove that hulkbuster
oh cool okay hulk you got it okay
i'm trying to hide behind these
i love that i think that's one of my
favorite moves of kamala just this fist
that just
goes out and just knocks them back
nice okay so we just hacked the servers
all the enemies disappeared
nice work i like to look around and see
if enemies dropped anything
because that tends to happen like right
over here see boom very important
i'm a collector i like to collect
especially if it means i can level up
my uh my avenger team
it isn't far look everywhere
everywhere ceiling walls floors
they do a really good job of hiding
strong boxes in this game
to like really rewards you for
exploration
me
you made it level five all right chat
what's the next skill point where do you
want it to go
let me bring it up so you guys can see
it
so options we have a spin attack or spin
kick
when you're running up you can spin kick
we have a leg sweep while dodging
if i push square i can trip them up
i have a sliding kick if i'm running up
i can hit my heavy attack button
and it will kick them i have a heavy
dodge attack
so as soon as i dodge if i do my heavy
attack it will have you attack back
i can catapult kick if i if i push my
heavy attack
i does a battering ram and then i come
up back at them and kick them
i have hammer fists so if i jump in the
air i hold triangle
i fist down and then i have harpoon
where i can grab someone and just
uh sweep them around like a rag doll
and then i have hip check which if i
push
as a counter if i counter i can i can uh
i can counter a little bit better use a
better period of strike so the choice
is yours what kind of kamala do you want
to see
let me know okay grab attack we got grab
attack good choice that's gonna be my
next
all right harpoon is up let's grab some
enemies
and throw them around
look at hold the shadow right there good
choice
good choice harpoon is going to be mine
too
there's so many easter eggs in this game
too
aim has an arc reactor close by
destroyed
let's see if i can grab
as soon as i see an enemy i can grab i'm
gonna grab
okay there's a strong box in here
oh we got gear yeah give me that gear
give me that gear
all right i love gear
okay nope let's deconstruct dismantle
that
nope let's dismantle that ooh
plus 12 plus three percent lowers my
heroic weight rating but i'm okay with
that because i want a higher
melee by 12 that's that's that's way
better and it's nine over seven
so i'm gonna dismantle that also if
you're someone who doesn't wanna go
through all the gear and read up on all
the powers and stuff
there's a button that you can push that
automatically upgrades your gear for you
to the best
gear power so you know depending on the
kind of gamer you are if you want to get
into
you know the the gear and you love the
lore and you love
what it does for your character you can
totally get into that but it also gives
you the option of you know what
i i trust that it's gonna upgrade me to
the best of my abilities i don't i don't
need to read this
i just want to get back into the game
you can totally do that too
so yeah however your play style is
there's a there's a way
i'm the opposite i want to read
everything you know i'm i'm a marvel
fanatic i wanna i wanna know everything
i wanna
check out those comics i wanna i wanna
check out the cosmetics i wanna see
every little
little detail energy junction okay let's
uh let's grab some we should destroy
that
oh i'm sorry did you have somewhere to
be yeah how about the wall
let's see if i can grab and put them
into the i start to destroy these
reactor cores
so i'm throwing them into the reactor
cords oh hi you wanted to join us
come join us
it's a party
oh man hulk's voice in the background oh
oh
it just feels like it's all around oh
whoa where did you all come from what
excuse me
okay let's heal maybe let's do a
challenge card no not yet
still any more healing for the challenge
guard let's get out of the way
see look at it because because of kamala
i'm able to fight
two exos at the same time because of
because of her attacks whereas black
widow would have to
probably focus on one unless she uses
her heroic ability
but because of kamala and even hulk
would have that ability too
you can focus on multiple enemies at the
same time which is why i'm a
huge fan of these type of characters
i want to do as much damage to many
different characters at once excuse me
did i say you can you can attack me oh
look see
i just i grabbed that enemy and gave
that enemy straight to black widow
i was like here you go so think how
strategic you can be when you're playing
online with friends
if you know if your friend is like iron
man for example and they got the rockets
charged up ready to go
i can grab an enemy i can throw that
enemy up in the air or to iron man iron
man can lock onto that enemy at the same
time
and then then you have a combo that's
all through communication
and using your best character abilities
what what
oh man
or even you could even do it to black
widow like i just threw it through that
enemy type of black widow
you can throw the enemy up in the air
black widow can shoot with it with her
guns
you know and then and then hope jump in
the air and smash them down
i know it's supposed to destroy these
reactor cores but i'm just having way
too much fun
just destroying these enemies
okay anybody here at sea last one it's a
party y'all yes
oh it came just in the last second all
right well
looks like you got lucky exo because you
would have been destroyed
mission complete and that was our first
war zone
that was like the tip of the iceberg for
that war zone there's so much more to
explore i believe there's a shield
hideout in that in that war zone there's
so many more strong boxes in that war
zone
will continue ooh insignia
so let's check out the gear that we got
because i know we got some gear
oh 12 yes okay so again that brings our
heroic rating down
but it brings everything up way more the
important thing for me is melee rating i
want melee rating to be really really
high
for kamala khan i love her range rating
but i'm i'm a getting up close and
personal type of player
if you're different then that's that's
awesome you know if you're more
defensive more ranged
the great thing about this is you could
have the kamala khan that you want to
have
going to boost this as well so as you
see the next book of the next boost perk
is is locked if i use
my resources to unlock it it's going to
ge i'm going to get 12
chance defeating an enemy which grants a
willpower burst
so let's go ahead and and unlock that so
now that second thing's unlocked
let's check here defense rating goes up
11 i've been putting a lot of heroic
rating down
so i don't know if i want to put heroic
rating down six percent because i've
been putting down a lot but my defense
rating is only 134
so she's been taking a lot of damage
this nine even though this nine for the
power is nine it's better than the seven
however it's not as good so i'm gonna
dismantle this nine
i'm not gonna equip this common vest and
the reason why
the vest that i have right now gives me
an 8.4 chance of pairing incoming
attacks
i already have a perk attached to this
gear they scared us no perk yes it gives
me a higher defense but
i think i'm okay i haven't been needing
defense as much
as these as i've been playing these
missions so i think i think i'm good
uh so for this one this is not uncommon
i have an uncommon equipped
i have a common that i can equip i don't
think i'm going to do this
because the 10 decrease in my melee to a
10 increase in my range to me is not
worth it
so dismantle and this one's good perfect
let's check do we have any uh
artifacts we're good there so this is
the gear that i have i
do have resources that i can you know
i'm going to boost this one i have
plenty of resources to use this one
let's check out cosmetics um
yeah so just to give you a preview of
these uh let's check out this one
you can check all these out
it's oh man there's just so many it's so
cool
we got some new name plates
that you could switch out it's whatever
you know whatever you love to do
cool y'all so just to give you a quick
recap what we just did
we just finished our very oh secure the
asset didn't do a very good job of that
one so it also rates you
uh in the beta i haven't found a uh
the rating system changes anything that
you get in terms of resources and
leveling
uh so for the beta so that so just
because i got a 90 that's fine i still
collected all the things i can collect
i don't know if that will change when
the game comes out so
we go into our character menu let's hit
continue we're gonna give that a five
out of five
absolutely so let's go ahead and
showcase some hulk and to give you a
recap we just did our first war zone
mission
with kamala khan you saw the expanse of
that entire war zone mission
you see the war table there's so many
more missions that you can do you can go
to the eastern seaboard
which i believe is another war zone
mission
because it's just it's massive you have
the entire area to like to go around
you have utah badlands which we showed
you both of the utah battle badlands
drop zones
uh quick get in get out missions we
showed you one pacific northwest
war zone which was up here on the top my
favorite mission so far
is to tame a titan but warning make sure
you have a team with you
you need a good team you need a really
really good team
it's awesome strongly recommend it just
make sure you have friends to play with
you or a really good ai team with you
that you've leveled up people because
you're going to need it
awesome so we're going to go ahead and
choose another drop zone mission
we're going to stick with the pacific
northwest
let's do uh alpha threat training
complex
and we just unlocked skills for kamala
we showed you some new gears for kamala
we got pretty in-depth on those gears
now we're gonna get into hulk showcase
some hulk action
let me oh let me make sure i have oh we
have gear for hulk we have a bunch of
stuff oh whoa okay
no not gonna helpful
we have some skills for hulk too we have
a skill point oh whoa okay hello
uh let's see i'm gonna choose this one
for now but i'm gonna totally
keep it open for the next skill point
that we get
so you can increase his rage uh for his
boost
15. i'm gonna unlock
while sprinting push square yeah i'm
gonna unlock sprinting push square
because it gets me into the action
faster but the next skill is definitely
gonna be yours
be ready be ready oh yeah let's get this
green light on because we're hulk now
y'all
yes as you see i did the lights did the
lights for you twitch fam
cool that's uh yeah splintered all right
oh just the breathing of hulk
power level seven level three
intel provided by our friends at shield
has revealed the location of an elite
aim squad
take out the targets and return to us
unharmed if possible
all right so we're taking out targets
quick jarvis wants us to be unharmed
can't make any promises
oh there's his on-screen walk
we got the beard he's not happy
close by and on alert updating your
heart
so he could throw he could throw these
boulders these rocks you can
upgrade the rocks or the debris
to even larger debris
so you can hit multiple enemies
what a beast what a beast
got okay three challenge points see on
the left siege master so i just did a
challenge card
uh that was a daily because i got three
points for it
i just did a daily challenge there's a
strong box right here i should actually
look at his his challenges hello there i
love how he kicks him
it's like all right open up all right
let's get into this challenge card too
so i'm at level six for hulk so defeat
grabbed enemies okay so i gotta grab
enemies
that's important defeat enemies with
heroic attacks okay
defeat 25 enemies without being
incapacitated
okay should be pretty easy hopefully
famous last words and then when he opens
these he just bangs on it
oh i was already in the thing but he did
he he like bangs on the keyboard
like each character has their own way
they interact with objects in the map
they thought of everything they thought
of everything like come on every member
of the elite team
showing off guys
so this is where i'd be like iron man
get out these get out these lasers up
top
oh let's get a move on this
oh he just tosses him get out of here
okay cool so i grab this enemy
because i want to do they attack enemies
with other enemies
[Music]
look at that i just did it weekly 11.
nothing stopping the whole
i wonder which weekly that was was that
destroyed 25
no way no way destroyed 50 enemy types
already
so on top you see a rage meter which is
that green green meter right on the top
basically i have a rage button
that i hold he does more damage and it
heals me
so hulk has his own healing abilities
okay let's uh oh good luck
i'd be terrified if i was these aim
soldiers i would be
terrified i'd be like no i'm calling out
sick today
absolutely not i'm not i'm not i'm not
coming to work
absolutely not like what would you do
man their health care better be good
that's all i got to say
they better have some good insurance
i wonder what these aim soldiers have to
sign in order to get hired
are you okay with the possibility of
hulk just rampaging straight at your
face
please sign here
be like no i'm not okay with that
i'm going to play hulk again because i
didn't show you all of his abilities
that i wanted to show
because that was just so captivated by
the destruction
oh man hulk's hulk's a lot of fun
poke's a lot of fun so that was a drop
zone mission
if jarvis could talk to me he'd be like
hey yo stop interrupting me dude
um so what's cool about this as well is
let's say you're someone who like
knows you only have maybe 10-15 minutes
in your day before you have to go to
work or something
cool let's get into a drop zone mission
really fast i just finished that in what
like seven minutes maybe a little bit
less i could have probably finished that
faster if i
was more focused that i just did a daily
and a weekly challenge
in one drop zone mission so i'm like
cool awesome
gear up level up awesome
okay so we uh we haven't unlocked a new
skill for hulk yet because we need to
level him up he's more than halfway
i'm not gonna oh this is not bad three
percent defense one one
four i'm gonna do it because
yes because this is common this is
uncommon i can boost this
so let me boost a lot of these
so let's go ahead and get into a harm
room mission
there are three harm room missions you
can do in the beta
once you finish one you unlock the next
one and then the next one
home rooms are are enemies come at you
in waves i believe there are 10 waves
that you can do
and it's a great way to skill up and
level up as fast as possible
they're not going to have any gear drop
so keep that in mind but it's also a
great way to unlike
unlock comics because each harmony
mission you do
you unlock a comic and comics give you
buffs in the game
uh percentages to increase your attack
percentages to increase this
let me actually let me actually show you
the comics before we get into that
because we didn't really talk about
comics so here's all the comics that you
can discover we have tons that are
undiscovered so far
we've we have one unlocked the
incredible hulk it tells you all the
information of the comic which is great
because as a comic book fan
i'm like oh man okay i want to go to
marvel unlimited and read all this stuff
like let me go check it out
and it tells you all about the comic so
this gives me point five percent status
resistance which is great the more
comics i get
the more buffs i get comic i strongly
recommend
getting in comics let me keep in
collections because you get intelligence
you get audio files that you can listen
to um
from different people that you know tell
you like from jarvis maria hill
to kamal khan so many different like
easter eggs and stuff and lore
you have the codex which teaches you all
about different enemy types as you see
task masters here
which is who we fought during a day you
know there's this
there's tons of stuff if you want to
like learn about all the enemy types and
stuff like that
but harm missions are a great way to
level up because you're defeating waves
upon waves of enemies
test out your character abilities if
you're like hey i'm going to try new
combos
i want to try out new new skill points
that i unlocked let me see how this one
feels
hey i just want to play as kamala khan i
want to play this black widow just to
get a feel
great way to do this a great way to
level up
so you're in the same place that we were
in before but now you're not alone you
have your entire avengers squad with you
and it's multi-player
so you can bring your friends in your
friends will play with you you can try
new combos out with them
i gotta grab enemies
ragdoll
yes so now that we've played as all four
chat who who's one of your favorite
avengers or who are you looking forward
to play as
are you more of a black widow get in get
out get invisible
range attack are you more of an iron man
you want to fly in the air
and help your your squad up in the air
and get those repulsors those lasers
those rockets
are you more of a hulk where you want to
smash everything
destroy everything get into the action
as much as possible
or you're more of a kamala khan you want
to attack as many enemies as you
possibly can
you want to you in big in polymorph you
want to grow
and heal more of a support
which yeah what what do you what do you
what what like what'd you love
hulk's also good at wall traversals he
can you can hold on to walls
jump around like that
all right wave two
yeah oh the elbow drop in the air
okay
also you have any questions let us know
in chat if you have any comments
let us know in chat we'll do our best to
answer them
they're done this game comes out on
september 4th marvel's avengers comes
out on september 4th i can't believe it
i can't believe it it's less than a
month away
i can't believe we're here
okay let's do an elbow jump with an
enemy in my hand
all right wave four okay i think that
was all of them for the time being
oh take take the shoulder
oh these so these guys explode you want
to watch out for them
there's so many different enemy types
you look hungry take some rocks
i should work on my quips i know
level four all right so as soon as this
wave ends
chat it's up to you for for skill points
you got to help me out from what i
remember
in terms of skill points let me go
really fast while we're in the middle of
a
wave so i can show you when you have
time to think we can
dodge per square to attack again we can
get a larger debris when we're throwing
rocks
we can push triangle when we're running
up for a big leap pound
we can hold triangle for a bigger ground
pound
uh we can grab an enemy and slam the
enemy onto the ground even further
we can grab an enemy slam the
enemy down to the ground and say jump
dude such a good way of describing these
or i can increase my rage meter by 15
points
which do you want to see the powers in
your hands
so this is number one if you're maybe
thinking oh wow this
you know you're doing a really good job
you know my level's really
you know these enemy types seem easy in
a sense yeah i mean i'm playing on a
normal difficulty
i can increase the difficulty by two
more points for sure if i wanted to
challenge myself
but there's also harmony number one out
of three the hit progressively more
difficult
number two number three you'll see more
bigger mechs
you know you'll see bigger enemy types
you'll see adaptoids
which are really really cool they're
like this
almost the size of hulk i think
all right wave six
these leaves these leaves
[Music]
what are you doing over here
come join the fun
i'm still i'm still holding him he
hasn't let him go
nice job black widow way to go
more oh you wanted to dodge that all
right all right all right
all right dude you're smart
you can also
i can use this debris as a
as a way to attack enemies too without
throwing it
that's one of the abilities i just used
as soon as we get to like wave eight
nine i'm going to show you
the cloud
this is just like it's just like it's
like candy
i can't stop i can't stop i can't
boulder to the first
oh didn't get you nice dodge
all right dash attack for next skill all
right let's get dash attack
which i believe it's the heavy dash
attack yes just want to confirm i want
to
give you guys what you want yep dash of
check here we go all right so i can run
and i can push my heavy attack button
i just punch into the ground
okay there's a time perfect time for
this ability
it breaks everybody's shield around me
it's a great area of effect
i just love the toss of you
everyone's open for a finisher
all right this is the last wave let's
get everyone together oh cool we got
some exos
we're gonna come all just stretching out
i'm closer everybody
come on over
all right here we go here we go yes
oh
the destruction
okay all right
there you go oh hulkbuster
okay dude too late man i just defeated
two exos and now you're bringing the
hulkbuster out
oh gotta get on the way to that oh did
it hit me i don't know
let's let's watch let's look let's watch
hulkbuster do this thing
oh come on i was like nope come on just
snatch that enemy right out of your face
iron man skill five
and a new emote we just unlocked two
two levels in one harm room that's how
quick it is
so i have another skill point i can
upgrade
i love that i love how iron man was
going to an enemy and kamala khan's like
mine
so cool
new comic all right let's get into all
this because we just did a harmony
mission so we got a new comic
you also find comics in in strong boxes
as well
okay let's see after executing a power
attack press triangle to perform another
massive radial attack i'm gonna choose
that one because that's
awesome it's more of a area effect
so let's get it so we didn't get any
gear because we did a harmony mission
harbor missions
um haven't been given us gear but what
it did give us
is a new emote um i believe maybe that's
my challenge card emote
got some name card but it gave us the
comic let's check out the comic
there we go thor god of thunder
heck yeah point five percent critical
chance
so let's check out my challenge card
i've done one weekly i've done one daily
defeat enemies with heroic attacks all
right we still have a couple more to do
in that one and grab
defeat grab the enemies okay we have a
lot to do in that one
so the next outfit that i have to unlock
is
this one oh that's so cool
oh man oh man so quick recap of what we
just did because we showed a lot
a lot a lot and there's still so much
more to this beta
just going to show you the war table
what we went over today we started as
kamala khan
we went to the home room tutorial we
played as iron man
from there we went to utah badlands did
two drop zone missions
it was get in get out we played as every
single character black widow kamala khan
hulk and iron man that you can play in
the beta
we showcased the gear the cosmetics
the challenge cards we got in depth into
this game and there's
still so many more hours to get into
this game and
for those of you who have pre-ordered on
xbox on pc the pre-order beta is live
today through the 16th sunday
so go in there get in play and for ps4
the beta is open right now for this
weekend as well
so play the game let us know you can
tweet at us
at marvel on all social media platforms
show us
those awesome photo modes show us what
level you're getting your favorite
characters whatever you want
man look for also the new war table
infos coming soon
i'm josh solay i'm still freaking out
i'm gonna be playing this game
the next 10 hours it's gonna be four in
the morning and i'll be like
what day is it where am i um so i'll
still be here guys
you all have a wonderful wonderful day
man this is marvel's avengers and it's
coming out on september 4th
get ready get hyped i'll see you next
time take it easy